Gundam Wing combined with Godzilla how
in the world can that possibly be bad
Pacific Rim is directed by Guillaume el
del Toro love that guy such an excellent
visual director I'm a big fan of the
Hellboy films Pan's Labyrinth is a
beautiful visual experience the man
knows how to make uniquely crafted
movies that look amazing a Pacific Rim
is a great opportunity for him to be
able to do that because this film is
essentially about a future time in which
these beasts have taken over the earth
and they're kind of just rampaging
around
they're known as kaiju in this film and
they basically look like a combination
of the Cloverfield monster and Godzilla
these things burst out of the ocean from
a portal that connects their world with
ours and they rampage around and have
fun for a while until humans invent a
new piece of technology that they call
Yeager's essentially it's a giant mecha
and two pilots get inside of this mecha
their minds meld and they're then able
to control the beast and fight these
monsters and that's essentially what
this movie is about you have different
characters presented throughout the film
that are there to have a story of some
kind but in reality you're going to see
this movie because you want to see
mecca's versus Godzilla and does this
movie deliver in that aspect yes it does
this movie has some of the coolest fight
scenes I've seen extremely fun to watch
terrific special effects - I mean
top-notch CGI an excellent 3d I would
strongly recommend seeing this movie in
3d which is not something I generally
say the 3d in this movie is terrific the
depth of field really feels like you are
looking into a tunnel of images and as I
said the CGI is excellent the monsters
look really cool this is something I was
concerned about because gebel del Toro
is very well known for creating terrific
prosthetic creatures and great makeup
work
yes he's most definitely done CGI I mean
I love Hellboy I love Hellboy 2 but for
the most part he does like to work with
a lot of prosthetics and all the fights
in this movie it's going to be 100% CGI
it's obvious and it all looks terrific
and extremely convincing never once did
I feel like I was actually looking at a
CGI image I was aware of it I mean I
know it's not real but I was able to get
into the scenes so much and I really
liked that element of this movie now all
I've really talked about is the visual
experience so far
that is really the best aspect of this
movie you're going to go into this movie
if you want to see monsters respects
it's going to be awesome and you're
going to have fun if you go to a movie
starring Godzilla or if you go to a
movie that stars giant robots are you
really there to see anything else
besides Godzilla or the robots yes it
would be nice if the actors are well
done this interesting characters when
you go to a Transformers movie what are
you really wanting to see you're wanting
to see Optimus Prime when you go to see
Pacific Rim you want to see these things
fight and you will get that and it's
awesome but I do have to say that aside
from two great performances in this
movie that of Idris Elba and Ron Perlman
who are just awesome in this movie just
about everything else isn't really up to
par with what I was hoping it would be
the main actor of the movie is Charlie
Hunnam and this guy gets recruited to
come back to the Jaeger program after a
tragedy happened to him so he has to
learn how to get back into it again he
has to be the hero that he used to be
his performance as this character was so
stilted and really not good and it pains
me to say that because he's the Luke
Skywalker of this movie he's the guy
that you're supposed to feel the blood
pumping through him and you're supposed
to feel when he's in that robot yes I
feel there's a human in there and I feel
like I'm with this thing and it's just
not like that now Mako is a character in
the film was a total badass she is
completely as strong as any of the guys
she can hold her own and she was a lot
better I thought but like I said hydras
Elba and Ron Perlman are fantastic in
the movie I love their characters that I
love their actors Idris Elba's character
had a lot of depth and you really got to
know him he had the most depth out of
anyone in the whole movie really I he
should have been the main character in
all honesty and Ron Perlman was just
awesome because he is awesome as a
person but at the same time his
character was really cool entertaining
and funny
Charlie days in the film as well and he
has annoyed me in the past but I kind of
liked him here because he did give
something more to his character than I
was expecting it's really just the main
guy honestly that really failed for me
because he was the character you're
supposed to really be rooting for I
couldn't feel a thing
for him like I remember there was one
part of the movie where a monster was
just like beating on his robot and I was
like if the monster reached in there and
ripped him out right now and killed him
in his hand I'd probably think that was
pretty awesome and I shouldn't think
that about the main character hero of
the film I guess that being said you go
to a movie like this to see robots
fighting dinosaurs and you get it
it's awesome and it's extremely well
done so for that reason I'm going to
give Pacific Rim of B I do think the
human element of the film could have
been much better and the performances
could have been better but it is still a
really enjoyable fun summer experience
with a lot of great action set pieces in
there and terrific CGI and I would
definitely recommend seeing it in 3d as
always guys thanks for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck menage